sound support from meps for a shift  towards more advanced less damaging  biofuels which use valuable land for  food once first generation biofuels were  seen as co2 friendly now as indirectly  dirty causing deforestation in asia and  latin america if we are able in europe  to  to make our own  biofuels on a sustainable level without  sort of  slash and burn tactics then i think we  indirectly  are helping the rest of the world the eu  wants 10 percent of transport fuel  renewable by 2020. meps capped that at  seven percent now giving investors in  early biofuels at least a chance to  recoup an investment they were  encouraged  we lost too much if we do it right we  can really have a decarbonization in the  transport sector but if we do it wrong  we are stimulating bad technologies and  that's what we would like to prevent  biofuel producers must also now report  to the european commission estimated co2  emissions arising from indirect land use  change that can lead to deforestation